want to do a couple interesting polling
stories not just normal polling stories
about the horse race but polling stories
that really go to a lot of what is
underlying sentiment in the United
States right now in our political system
yesterday I mentioned to you that 49% of
Americans in a recent poll said that
impeachment proceedings should start
against Donald Trump this by itself is
already a stunning number but it's sort
of softened I guess you could say by the
reality that starting impeachment
proceedings isn't necessarily saying
Trump should be removed
you might just believe there's enough
evidence to warrant starting those
proceedings but you're sort of open to
whatever conclusion those proceedings
might come to that was yesterday there
is now a new poll which says that 47% of
Americans straight-up
think that Donald Trump should be
removed from office period and with
every one of these polls that are
historically shocking like this is
historically a shocking number my shock
continues to be that only 47% of
Americans believe that Donald Trump
should be removed from office which gets
me back to what I said yesterday which
actually I would you know most of the
time when I say something negative about
a group of voters even if it's a group
of voters that most people in our
audience disagree with I will get some
emails from people saying you know David
you really it's better if you don't say
that the optics aren't good about you
saying I did not get that when I said
yesterday if you don't believe that this
man is a systemic danger to the United
States and to the world that you were
part of the problem and that's where I
returned today if you think that what's
going on right now is even remotely okay
you are either unaware of what's going
on
sort of like an ignorance is bliss type
of thing or you are part of the problem
because it's embarrassing that merely
47% of the country thinks that Donald
Trump should be removed from office
40% 47% is a high number looking back at
other presidents
but it is way way way too low
considering what it is that we're
dealing with today and I was interested
in looking at this in the context of
history as a point of historical
comparison I went back to Richard Nixon
because increasingly we see more and
more sort of parallels between Watergate
and the Trump Fiasco administration
presidency
I believe that when Richard Nixon
ultimately resigned somewhere between 55
and 57 percent of the country believed
that he should be removed so the numbers
are not that far from that point so most
importantly step one here no matter
where you are on impeachment indictment
resignation removal under the 25th
amendment the agenda of Trump and his
cronies you need to vote every single
one of them out in November every single
one that is up for re-election needs to
be voted out in November that's just a
little over seven weeks to go then we
need to have this conversation about
what is wrong with the people of this
country because something is very wrong
that only 47 percent think that it's
time for Trump to go and we've talked
about there's all sorts of these rules
of thumb and politics like 20% of the
population will always support the
president 20% will never support the
president it's the other 60% that can
sort of be swayed by what actually
happens and that's probably a factor in
in what these numbers are
I think that these circumstances are so
extenuating and so outrageous that they
really should be going well above and
beyond what these historical numbers
have been and when it comes when it
comes to Watergate by the way I think
that the the Watergate comparison is apt
not in terms of the seriousness or scope
of what was done we at this point know
what it was that Richard Nixon did we
don't yet know what it is that Donald
Trump and his cronies have done
the parable the parallel nature of
Watergate and Trump includes the way in
which Trump's behavior has become
increasingly erratic as a result of the
investigation the ways in which Donald
Trump has tried to suppress that
investigation in the way that we saw
done during Richard Nixon's time the
ways in which Donald Trump has turned
the investigators themselves into the
enemy even though there's not any
evidence that they're actually the ones
guilty of wrongdoing so there are
definitely parallels in terms of the
subject matter in terms of what was done
by who and when we're gonna have to wait
and see but what I do want to talk about
next and this is the next poll we're
going to discuss today relates exactly
to the smearing of the investigators
this episode is sponsored in part by
better help calm slash Pakman which
gives you access to a fully licensed and
experienced psychologist or therapist
through video phone and text I know from
the emails I get that in our audience
like in the broader world there are
people who are struggling with different
issues in their lives and many of them
choose not to talk to somebody about it
either for financial reasons for reasons
of stigma associated with seeking out a
therapist and I think it's really
important to do everything you can to
get past that because it's really
important to talk to someone when you
feel like that's the right thing to do
and what better help calm provides is
number one the elimination of the stigma
that could be associated with it you
work through video phone whichever
method is best for you you also will be
able to save money compared to seeing an
in-person therapist and it is so easy to
get started that I encourage you to go
to better help calm slash Pakman a few
questions that you answer which will get
you paired up with a therapist that
meets your needs you can always switch
to somebody else if you don't feel as
though the match is a good fit and it is
something that everyone
should have access to go to better help
calm slash Pakman it's easy to sign up
it's easy to get started we've put a
link in the description if you're
watching on YouTube and once again that
website is better help calm /pa que ma n